they had an amazing victory the teachers
strike in West Virginia and I didn't see
hardly anything in the corporate media
about this on any of the networks even
some of the networks that we watch you
know Russia turn the channel Russia all
the shiny keys to distract us that's
what goes on in the media hate to admit
it but he's absolutely right
when even left-wing standard bearers
like Michael Moore not a genius find
themselves annoyed by the year-long
obsession with Russia maybe somebody's
going on will it change anything about
the way news is covered I don't know Joe
Concha writes about this stuff for a
living he joins us to predict so I mean
look presumably this guy don't you know
he doesn't like the administration he's
got every incentive to want to cheer on
the endless cover coverage of Russia but
even he's tired of it is there a limit
to how much the press can cover this one
story is called a sack of a story
apparently no Tucker I mean look there
are three different investigations still
going on it deserves coverage but their
degrees to everything and Bernie Sanders
was exactly right and he actually said
on CNN just a couple of weeks ago to
Anderson Cooper's face when when he
bought up stormy Daniels for example and
and I'm quoting here there are enormous
problems facing our country and what are
we talking about over and over again
stormy Daniels and you could agree or
disagree politically with Bernie Sanders
but I think his authenticity is
something that can't be questioned and
he added let me respectfully suggest I
don't think stormy Daniels is one of the
major issues facing our country and it's
the same thing with Russia I mean this
has now been going on for what 14 15
months and leaks happen all the time out
of this government even out of the DOJ
and the FBI and we still haven't seen
anything substantial so yes let the
investigation continue but there are
degrees to everything and I think
basically we're at our limit let me just
add what me Preston said she's a
national political reporter for CNN
she's a good one she said so far out in
these districts when you talk to people
about Russian that's all we talked about
at CNN basically this is to get every
reporter saying this
they say they don't care those are
voters it doesn't have any effect on our
lives and I think that sums it up nicely
Tucker do you think jeff zucker persist
look this is an international network
we've got bureaus all over the world are
we really pretending that Russia is the
single greatest threat to American
national security like it's clearly not
even on the top five list do you think
they feel dishonest when they present
Russia as this imminent threat to
America I think you're referring to
maybe a Bloomberg poll that came out
last year that had it down the list in
terms of priorities and Americans say
the media should be talking about I
think it did come in six so you're right
with that number
whatever the CNN President is deeming as
far as an important story it seems that
if it isn't Russia it's always it's
negative to the president it seems like
that's the direction that the network
and other media outlets will go in
because they feel that they're giving
comfort food to their audience telling
them what they want to hear instead of
perhaps of what they should hear even if
it's something boring like the economy
jobs Isis and things that as me breast
instead affect people's lives I think
they believe it cuz I mean there are
many nights when we do another story
that's not Russia all of a sudden our
college I can't believe you're ignoring
the real news Russia it's Carter page I
read I think they kind of believe it you
may be right
yeah I can't disagree with you in any
capacity there I want to make me feel
better but you didn't but it's great see
anyway Joe thank you okay good to see
you